I'm Carol Kushner. I'm from California. And I'm
here representing being identified with the BRCA2 mutation.
>> And I want to, I want to before we
get into the BRCA2 mutation, I want to know a
little bit more about you. I mean, you, you
live in California now. Where, where you from originally?
>> Well I was born in New York, raised in New Jersey, and went to college in
New York and got married out east, and we moved to California in the late 70s.
>> Okay. Wow, so you've been in California for a while now.
>> Right.
>> And what do you, what do you do for
fun? What do you, what do you do in California?
>> Well, I do pulaties, I bike, I hike.
And I'm very interested in
genealogy and family history.
>> And do you know much about
your family's background and where your family's from?
>> Well, I know about up to as far as my grandparents. Eastern Europeans.
And I've also worked on my daughter-in-law's
family and they go back to the Mayflower.
>> Oh wow. Wow you were able to trace back that far.
>> Right.
>> Wow, that's, that's pretty cool. and
have you ever visited, do you feel special
connection with family history? Have you visited
Eastern Europe? and is that meaningful to you?
>> Well actually it's on my list of places to go. we've
been, we've traveled a lot, but we haven't been to eastern Europe.
>> I see. Well, let's come back to
this BCRA2 mutation. tell, can you tell us a little bit
more what, what is the BRCA2 mutation that you have? And what does it mean?
>> Well, I have the one mutation is that was
tested and reported is
6174 dell T. And it is a pretty common mutation in
Ashkenazi Jewish people. And an uncle of mine is
also has the same mutation. And my cousin, his daughter.
>> I see. So this appears to be a
familial mutation that seems to be in other family members.
>> Right, it is a familial mutation, but as
I mentioned, it is common in Ashkenazi Jewish background.
>> And what does having this mutation mean? Well, actually, maybe we
should ask this in order. when did you find out you had the mutation?
>> I found out in early 2010.
>> Okay.
>> And it was a surprise. I did the 23andMe
genetic testing and the results came back and it was surprising.
>> And what did they tell you it means? what,
like you have this mutation, what does it
mean what is for you? For an individual?
>> Well, the risk of breast cancer is increased, compared
to the general population. And the risk of ovarian cancer is increased.
>> And do you know what those
increased risks were, what those percentages were?
>> Well, for the breast cancer risk, it's between
20 and 50% risk. Although I saw a higher number earlier when I looked
recently. It seems like the risk, the number I saw change. And for
ovarian cancer, the risk is much lower but the risk is higher than in the
general population. Now you can also calculate the risk based on age.
So compared to the general population the
risk for breast cancer at my age of 70 is four,
about 4.5 out of 100 compared to about 2.5 out
of 100 for not, a woman at age 70, who does not have the BRCA2 mutation.
>> I see. And what did you think about this whole, sort of probability issue?
You know, the idea of a percentage, I mean,
I think a lot of people think genetics is going to
tell them, oh, I am or I am not going
to have this trait. What was running through your mind?
>> A lot.
[LAUGH]
I am married to a physicist who understands statistics,
and he must have explained this to me half a dozen times, and all I could focus
on was the high number. But of course as you get older,
the risk it changes, it varies.
Assuming that there are 100 people, 100 women
with the BRCA mutation, and 50 have already, 50 out
of 100 have already had breast cancer
then, the statistics changed. That I can't really explain it but
it is daunting to think that there's, you know, double
the risk of someone else my age, even if it is a low number. Sure,
I mean I can imagine it sounds like you
discovered that okay there's a lot of math, there's a
lot of research behind the numbers. But the numbers
are still the numbers, and I imagine, you know, it
has sort of an anxiety effect on, on an
individual. Did you feel anxious or worried? And what did
you end up doing? Did you, did you, did it
change anything for you and did you take an action?
>> Well,
I was very anxious. And I called my doctor, he was away. I called
another doctor and he was away. And I called a friend who works at one of the
local hospitals. And I said, this is the situation. What do you recommend I do?
And she gave me the name of a doctor. And it was confirmed. By the time
I had that information, it was confirmed. By the doctor who had returned. So I
went to see a breast oncologist and at a very
large medical center. And at the same time
she scheduled me to see a genetic counselor which
is recommended when you, when you get this information it's recommended
that you. speak to someone, and see someone who
understands the genetics. so I did see this person, and
the physician and the genetic counselor on the same day and she
was, gave me a very thorough exam, and a very thorough explanation, there was no
rush. And I was advised
to consider strongly having my ovaries removed and
to have twice a year breast exam and
one time a year. A breast MRI and a breast
mammogram. And I've followed up, I've already followed up two times.
I see her twice a year and I've had the MRI and breast exam twice.
>> Wow. You took a lot of action.
>> I did.
>> And this was all based on the advise and the the I should say the,
the medical advise of a genetic counselor and your clinician?
>> Right. Right. And the genetic counselor took a history of everyone
in the family. mother, mothers, fathers,
grandfathers and. It was interesting to,
to find out my grand, my maternal grandmother died when my
mother was five. So we're talking about 1920s.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And like I was always told my grandmother died of stomach
cancer, and the genetic counselor brought up the possibility that she had
had ovarian cancer. Course, we wouldn't know, and this was the 1920s. And that
was what we, we heard. That she died of stomach cancer.
But it could've been ovarian cancer.
>> Wow. What what did this effect have on your
anxiety about the information, about your sort of medical future.
>> Oh, it made me very anxious. but I keep busy. I
work. So, it's, it's something that's in the back of my mind, it's not
invisible, but I took action. I had my ovaries removed, and
it was a pretty simple procedure. everything they completely
analyze all the slides and everything was clear so.
For that, I am grateful, and I'm following up on the mammograms and exams.
>> And so far,
it's all good news.
>> So far, so good.
>> I'm glad to hear that. in this process, was it
just a personal decision for you, or did you include family
members in, in discussing it and trying to figure out what
to do as well? Well I'll be married 50 years in.
>> Congratulations.
>> 2014. I'm very close with my husband and he and I discussed
this and it just seemed like it was the right thing to do. Of course I read a
lot. and I had family members who
had breast cancer and ovarian cancer. And
none of them are BRCA2 or any BRCA, for that matter.
So, it wasn't as if I knew anybody that had this,
was in this situation. Do you even can you tell us
that, it sounds like you, you did a lot of reading and
researching yourself, trying to learn about it. Do you know what
the, the BRCA genes do in a cell or in the body?
>> Well, if you have, you have a BRCA gene, and if you
have a normal gene which regulates the,
have a non-cancer cells will be working, then you wouldn't
be subject to the risk of breast cancer, ovarian cancer. Based on just
that BRCA gene. However, if you have the mutation, there is, as far as I
understand it. There's, in my particular case, I'm missing
the T.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And the whole, Gene shifts, the BRCA gene is shifting and there's
a mutation. And so it's not operating correctly, is my best understanding.
>> That's a pretty good understanding however the,
the mutation in the resulting protein that doesn't work
so well. it doesn't seem to lead to completely breast cancer,
ovarian cancer in all people who have it, as you mentioned. what are some of
the environmental things that a, that a clinician or genetic counselor talked to
you about? The environmental components that, that may play a part in this?
>> Well I was asked how much alcohol I
drink and I said well I live in California. You
know, I often have a glass of wine with dinner. And so its, they
don't know, its not for certain but they're recommending not
drinking too much alcohol. And as far as the environment
goes, there was really nothing much to. That they
discussed, but I, we eat healthy and
I moderate my wine drinking.
>>
[LAUGH]
It sounds like you lead a pretty healthy lifestyle, so that's good.
I'm, I'm actually curious, I'm curious to know
sort of there's this sort of personal feeling. And an
idea of, you know, when you find out.
Did anyone in your family have anxiety for you,
as well. Or did, were other family members
concerned? And did they interpret it the same
way you did? Did they only listen to
you for information? Did they look in other places?
>> Well, a lot of people in my family.
Took the 23andMe test. our sons, our two sons, my
husband, because his mother had breast cancer, he took the test.
our daughter-in-laws took the test. We asked an
Uncle my paternal Uncle, to take the test and he was BRCA2
and his daughter took the test and she's BRCA2. So
one of our son's is BRAC2. So they all, my sister took
the test and she was negative. Forgot about my sister. And
another cousin on my mother's side took the test. And she was negative also,
but she found out she had some hearing loss. A,
a gene that affected hearing, could affect hearing. She isn't affected,
but her grandson, she found because of that, they identified that the grandson
>> Mm-hm.
>> Who had
some hearing issues had the same mutation. So
everybody was supportive and understanding. But I'm pretty open person
so, they just took it, and they took my lead.
>> You mentioned that one of your sons
has the BRCA2, but the other son does not?
>> Right.
>> It's great that you were able to be sort of an example and a leader for
your family in sort of how to tackle information like this.
Did anyone else? Wa, was, in general, was everyone else's reaction
the same. You mentioned that you had female relatives who may
be younger than you who also had the mutation. Did they,
>> Well, my one cousin is in the process right now.
>> I see. I see.
>> Of scheduling an appointment for surgical
removal of her ovaries, oophorectomy.
>> I see. So it sounds like, you
know, there's, everyone's sort of going to talk
to their doctor and make these decisions about
what's the best action to take for themselves.
>> And she saw a genetic counselor as well.
>> So I'm also curious to know what else you found out from your genetic
report. You said you went to 23 in the end. Was, was the BRCA2 mutation,
the only surprise you found?
>> Well, I found out that I had a little risk
for Alzheimer's disease, but I'm not so sure that was accurate.
>>
[LAUGH]
>> I also found that and I have the
Tay-sachs mutation. And Tay-sachs is another
Ashkenazi Jewish genetic mutation and
Since I'm not having any children and my
husband wasn't a carrier, then I didn't
really worry about it but I was surprised.
if you have a pregnancy, and you're
baby's identified as having Tay-Sachs, the result of
a Tay-Sachs baby is they die within a couple of years of
birth. And it's a lipid storage.
Disease where
the baby is missing an enzyme that metabolizes a lipid, and this lipid, norm,
is normally metabolized, but when you have
the mutation where when you have Tay-Sachs disease.
the lipid accumulates in the brain.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And, the baby dies.
>> Wow. So, although you knew about your, your ancestry, and you knew
you were, you know, part of this Ashkenazi Jewish population and, or lineage,
and and, you know, there were maybe certained. certain variants that you may
carry. You didn't know which ones and this was, you know, news to you,
to be a carrier was.
>> Right, right. It was.
>> do you know if your sons are also carriers?
>> I don't remember. It was more
the BRCA2. I also have Gaucher's disease.
And that's another lipid storage disease in Ashkenazi
Jews, but not limited to Ashkenazi Jews.
>> I see.
>> And that's, and they're both carriers because I
have the disease. You mentioned you're a carrier of
Tay-Sachs and you don't, not sure if your sons
have the mutation as well. And they could be carriers.
would it effect, if you hadn't had kids yet, you were planning
your life. Would, is this something that would be important to you,
making sure before, you know, you had children with a particular mate,
making sure that person was not a carrier of Tay Sachs as well?
>> Well with the information we have today,
I certainly would inquire and have my husband tested.
And take action if there. I would want to make sure
that we were tested and if I were to get pregnant
I'd want to know if the baby I was carrying had Tay Sachs or not.
>> You said your sons are carriers. And have
your sons have, have they had any biological children yet?
>> yes, they each have two sons.
>> They each have two sons.
>> Right, one son is, does not have BRCA2 mutation.
>> Oh, that's right.
>> One son does. And they both have two sons.
>> I see, so this, I was just wondering if there's any,
anxiety. I mean the fact that you're a carrier and one son is a
carrier for the BRCA2 mutation, I guess it manifests more in females than males,
>> Right. But there is a risk for male breast cancer and, and
they believe there may be a link to prostate cancer. And
the they don't seem. The one son just seems to be taking
it in stride. And not focusing on it right now.
>> You know, there're a lot of people in the general population. Who, some who
don't know very much about genetics. And
as this information becomes more widespread. And they
discover, like you, that they have a
BRCA2 or BRCA1 mutation. females in particular who
don't know very much. if you had any advice to tell somebody who just found
out that they have a BRCA1 one or BRCA2 mutation. Is there anything you think
is important for them to know, or any
particular advice or message you would give them?
>> Well, if someone does inquire, and finds out,
I certainly think they should get genetic counseling and
see a physician who is a specialist in breast oncology
who is aware of the the latest and greatest research. we're
fortunate to live in an area where there are wonderful hospitals
and research centers. And so I strongly advise
people to take action and do what's best
for them. I know age is a factor. If you find out you're
in your 20s or 30s and you haven't started a family or had children yet,
what's recommended might be entirely different than what was recommended for me.
>> Great. Carol, thank you so much for being here.
>> Thank you for exploring this topic.